hello belief nation I want your thoughts
on what topics you want me to answer for
you something getting a lot of emails a
lot of tweets a lot of YouTube comments
a lot of messages from people who have
questions for their business from you
guys who want help in growing your
company you have specific questions for
me and it's been impossible for me to
get back to everybody and so what I
wanted to do was use this channel use
this series as an opportunity to answer
questions from you guys and either make
a seven ways video to help answer your
question or maybe something else but I
want to use this video right here this
video in the comments below for you guys
to write down the questions and the
topics that you want me to cover and so
what we'll do is every week as I go
through this look at which are the most
popular questions which one will help
the most of you and that's what make a
video on so if you have a question for
me that you'd like me to cover leave it
down in the comments below if you want
to vote on the ones that you want to see
me answer and make a video on then give
it a thumbs up to the people who
commented below and every week and go
through and look at the top ones and
those are the ones we are going to make
videos on so as the test is some
experiment I'd love to know what you
guys think looking forward to seeing
your comments down below much love
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon